still not a believer in liberal media
bias take a listen to this
the press is now openly rooting for jen
saki
white house reporters gushing over the
press secretary in a magazine feature
saying things like she takes questions
from everybody
she doesn't get rattled she doesn't lose
her cool
she's a pro you know she's unflappable
and she's like any other competent
professional pleasant lovely
press person from any other era
i don't know dana is jen saki getting 10
questions a day about how racist her
boss is or
how her administration is treasonous or
trying to hurt women and children and
immigrants i
i haven't seen that yet she is not
getting no she is not getting that i
don't think i've seen press like that
for a press secretary since tony snow
uh the press as i recall i mean as i
just remember they absolutely
loved him uh he would love to spar with
them from the podium but he was such a
did it in such a gentle way and also he
was um
uh he was just friendly to everybody
he'd bring cookies in and things like
that
not that he was bribing people and not
that that would have worked anyway
uh in a republican administration the
other thing with these
with the reporters many of whom i know
is i would just say like i've said with
dr fausch like you don't have to answer
every press call
you can take a pass like it's okay take
the weekend off you don't have to answer
it um if that's how you feel great
but you don't always have to advertise
it
greg i remember the day that trump's
guys killed soleimani
the press room was hostile when he
when he broke her to mid east peace deal
the day the press room was hostile i
mean
come on the guy couldn't get a break it
is
being a press spokesman for a democrat
is a really
really easy job because every time every
if you're playing with the home you're
you're on the home field advantage
right you're dealing with a media whose
toughest question will be
what's your recipe for brownies i think
she did make them brownies
so uh so it's like it's kind of like
it's kind of like running a
ice cream parlor on a hot day everybody
there is just really happy to see you
and i love how like the compliments they
were giving her was that too sunny
professional doesn't get rattled
this they were basically sub tweeting
the prior administration it really
wasn't an argument
it was like they had this idea like
let's it was kind of all directed at the
people before her
uh and and and they had to stretch it to
an improbable degree
and uh because i mean i'm sure jen
sackey
is very nice i don't doubt that but is
she nicer than kaylee
is she nicer than dana i don't know i
just think that it has nothing to do
with niceness they just don't like
dana's or kaylee's politics
they like jen's politics can i just add
one thing to what greg just said
my advice always to the private sector
is that if you're hiring a
communications person
and you want somebody with a political
background always go with somebody that
worked in republican politics because i
guarantee you
they have worked so much harder we've
seen it all
that's a good point that's good advice
yes and you can't bake people brownies
when you're working
in the publix in the private sector
degan that doesn't really work that way
yeah but after all that gushing and
falling and from those reporters what do
we get to see
next them cleaning out her refrigerator
for
or maybe waxing her legs in public
that's next they're gonna have to change
their
job titles to professional footstool
i don't think peter ducey is going to be
waxing jen's legs do you want no i'm
not going with that peter but i think
i'll just move us away from this
but i will say you know in my experience
i press secretaries
are often celebrated i i remember jim
brady
for reagan was a toast to the town i
think arie fleischer
uh did pretty well joe lockhart uh
mike mccurry under clinton jay carney
josh ernst you know these guys under
obama
no i didn't i said don't forget dana
purina don't forget marlin
yeah i agree marlon but what about
tony snow and dana perino you know i
think that you're not
i think the problem here is that's a
contrast
to the people who are working for donald
trump but they were at a disadvantage
because they had to defend all the lies
about the
inauguration size all of his grievances
and it you know it's even yesterday he's
going on about the election with stone
that stuff just gets
difficult and it put them in an
untenable position
all right all right well maybe juan
they'll ask about biden hiding children
when the press shows up you think he'll
ask about that hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else